>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Nick Brown: This is -- we're all
familiar, it's wonderful of course.
Thank you all, for being here
in the middle of the day.
Especially those of you who
are not Library employees,
a good many of you here, so
that's really great to see.
My name is Nicholas Brown,
I'm a music specialist
in the music division,
where I'm on the team
with the concert outlets
programing the concert series,
and the various public
programs that we do around that.
One of my great pleasures of
working here is to engage in one
of my other passions, which
is musicological research,
and today I'm very
excited to share some
of the results with that with you.
This is a topic that I've been
looking into for many years,
even back when I was
coming to the Library
to do research, as a student.
So, the tittle of the talk is
Hindemith's Musical Responses
to World War One, before we get
started I just want to give a shot
out to the interpreter program's
office, because this lecture is part
of the programing for two
World War One's exhibits
that the library has going on.
One of them is open right now, and
the other one opens on April fourth,
they are -- exhibits are title
World War One, American Artist View
of the Great War, and the second
one is Echoes of the Great War,
American Experiences
of World War One.
So, check that out.
You're all invited to take your
phones out and live Tweet this talk.
You can also take pictures of
the collection items or put them
up on Instagram or whatever
else you would like.
Please tag the library when
you do that, @librarycongress
and you're also invited to use
the Hashtag World War One; WW1,
and my personal handle
is there for Twitter,
if you would like to tag me as well.
Great. So, this is a quote by one of
Hindemith's principal biographers,
and you can read it, but I will read
it as well, "He was never a patriot,
yet he was deeply attached
to his German roots.
And the true test came
when his country was taken
over by totalitarian regime".
So, that kind of introduces
this biograph on there,
that's going on in Hindemith's life.
So, he grew up and came of age
in the World War One period,
and then had significant conflict
with the regime during
the Nazi period,
which then drove his departure
from Germany, eventually went
to Switzerland, came to U.S
and made his way back later on.
But, the purpose of this talk is
to very much take a close dive,
just on the World War One period,
and the years immediately following,
where Germany and Hindemith
were very much trying
to put things back together.
Because, Germany of course,
was a mess several years
there, after the war.
And so, this is a wonderful
picture of Hindemith in uniform,
in World War One, with his bio,
that's from 1918, I couldn't come
up with a clever enough bio joke, so
you're allowed to put your own in,
and there's a space there for that.
So, while you're checking out
Hindemith, I'll just give you a bit
of an overview of his
biography, for those of you
who aren't so familiar with him.
And then, after that, we're going to
shed some light on some of his role
in World War One, and some of the
music he composed during the period.
And we'll also do a
close reading of one
of his World War One
ear response works,
and then we'll discuss Hindemith's
relationship to the Library,
because that's the only reason
I'm allowed to talk about him,
because he had a relationship,
and we have collections
that are related to Hindemith.
So, there's Hindemith in a string
[inaudible] I'll get to this
on the narrative, so just peruse
that, while I give you some tidbits.
So, Hindemith was born in Hanau,
Germany near Frankfurt,
on November 16, 1898.
He died also, in Frankfurt in 1963.
He was the oldest of three
siblings; learned the violin first,
then he started studying composition
at the Hoch's Konservatorium
[phonetic] in Frankfurt.
One of his teachers
was Arnold Mendelssohn,
who was the great nephew of Felix.
He was also the same
teacher of Adorno,
which I find very interesting.
Hindemith didn't stick with the
violin, and he later switched
over to viola, and became
a composer of course,
he was a significant music theorist,
an educator, and a conductor.
He also published several
theoretical treatises
and some pedagogical texts as well.
So, getting into the
World War One time frame,
that was a very brief overview of
his biography, go read something,
you don't want to hear me
ramble about that all day.
So, World War One.
Hindemith's father; Robert Rudolf
Emil Hindemith, was born in 1870 --
was one of the driving forces behind
Hindemith becoming a musician.
He was a musician, he forced
his children to pretty much get
in the track to become musicians.
He was very active in getting
Hindemith opportunities
with teachers, putting him into
conservatories with scholarships,
and even opening the door for jobs.
Just about the time of 1914,
the relationship soured,
I haven't gotten in enough
depth in the German text,
to see exactly why that was.
It seems like Hindemith, probably
didn't talk too much about it.
But, right about the time
that it became strange,
Hindemith's father went to fight
in World War One, since 1914,
and he was killed within
that first year of conflict.
So, that left Hindemith's
mother without the income
for the household, and
Hindemith had to quickly adapt
to become the principal
bread winner for the family.
He joined the Frankfurt opera
orchestra in 1914, he was promoted
to Deputy Leader, Deputy
Concert Master later that year,
and he became the Concert
Master in 1917.
Hindemith was very evolved
in chamber music playing,
notably joining the
Rebner String Quartet,
from 1915 as the second violinist,
and later in 1923, was the switch
to viola that we mentioned earlier.
So, Hindemith was busy working in
Frankfurt, he was a freelancer,
he also had these permanent gigs,
where he was relatively well paid,
compared to a lot of other people.
And he kind of got away with not
having been conscripted initially,
because there was a draft.
One of the biographers goes
in depth into something
that really puts the effect of
World War One into perspective; so,
Hindemith, on the outside of
the war, had a lot of German,
nationalist kind of concepts.
Not super nationalist, not super
imperialist like other folks.
But, you can see his
attitude towards the war,
and towards his own
government positions evolved
over the course of the war.
So, on September 23rd,
1914; Hindemith said, quote,
"Everyone is glad that the
French are getting a good blow,
and if one goes into town
towards noon, or in the evening;
there's a crowd such as one
seldom notices in peaceful times,
in the entire empire
there's the great optimism
that Germany will win, and when
you see all the happy soldiers
that are still here,
and the enthusiasm,
you know this cannot be otherwise.
Everyone is delighted to go
into the field, and when you see
that everyone is happy to grab
a weapon, and no one wants
to stay behind, even
enemies will have to admit
that the German people are fighting
for a just cause, and have not,
as the French, Russian and
English live factories,
wished to propagate gun to
war, just for rowdiness.
Don't think that what I'm
writing is an exaggeration.
The numbers are set too low,
the people are set in a state
of enormous enthusiasm", obviously,
that didn't last for most people,
and the central powers
there just given the scale
of destruction and death.
Hindemith was initially
called up for service in 1915,
but he was rejected and he wrote of
this to some friends, "They haven't
yet taken me up into the ranks
of the defenders of our country,
and I'm not angry about it.
I was examined twice,
but was rejected due
to general physical
weakness and heart defects.
There will probably be more
examinations coming up,
and I have no hope of
coming back again."
So, that's within a year,
he's from September 14,
to September 15 his attitude
just switched, and maybe,
there was out of context going
on, but that's what we have
in some correspondence to go off of.
So, he was eventually
conscripted, and in August of 1917,
and throughout these first
few years of the war,
he was just in Frankfurt
working, basically.
And his training period
started on August 1917,
and then in January 1918, he was
sent close to the front in Alsace,
with a regime, and eventually on
to Flanders, on the summer of 1918.
One of the things that shows
Hindemith's entrepreneurial skill,
or persuasive skills, is
that he lobbied the director
of the Frankfurt Opera Theater, to
keep him on salary in his position,
while he was off fighting.
So, nowadays if you're in
the military and you work
for the government, you have 15 days
of military leave a year,
which is very generous.
So, basically getting paid
leave time, be in service,
but it expires at a certain point.
Hindemith actually
negotiated to get 70%
of his salary paid while
he was away and not working
for the Opera Orchestra,
which is pretty cool.
And his boss there, was generous
and didn't seem to put up much
of a fight about that,
given that the --
he very much asked for empathy,
because of his mother situation
and not having a father anymore.
So, in the war, Hindemith was
assigned to the regimental band,
this is a good place for
professional musicians
to go during sort of
total war situations,
it's the same in the American
military in World War One,
World War Two; folks
like Glenn Miller,
serving Elvis during his
little PR service, right?
And Hindemith, because
it was basically a brass
and percussion sort of -- Drum
and Bugle Corp kind of ensemble,
he played bass drum, there
was not an opportunity
for him to play the violin.
That is initial entry
to the regimental band.
He kind of seems to have
appreciated that he was
in a cushy service job basically,
and he wrote to some friends in May
of 1918, quote, "I can hardly
imagine most musicians as soldiers;
Bach as a staff Sargent,
that would still be OK,
but Beethoven practicing rightful
drum, Mozart throwing hand grenades,
or standing guard in
front of a barracks.
Shubert as an Air Force Lieutenant,
and Mendelssohn as an NCO
at a vehicle fleet convoy that
is inconceivable", end quote.
So, Hindemith did have down time, in
which to compose, and very quickly
after he got tired of
playing bass drum alone,
he joined in a string quartet with
some others in the military service,
and that became a big
part of his duties,
was to play string
quartet repertoire
for the commanding officer, who
was a very sort of well read,
learned type of guy who
enjoyed this classical music.
And that was a really
good opportunity
for Hindemith to take advantage of.
So, they were mostly
back from the frontlines,
as a result of his entertainment
role, and ceremonial role,
and eventually, they did get sent
in to sort of guards situations,
which I'll get into a second,
but one of the evenings or days,
where he was performing
for the commanding officer
in the string quartet, they happened
to be performing Debussy's
[phonetic] Quartet,
and while they were
performing they got word
that Debussy had passed away.
This was in 1918, March 25th
was when he passed away.
Hindemith is -- one of his most
well-known quotes is the following,
quote, "We did not
play to the end --
this is referring to that
performance of the Debussy --
it was as if our playing had been
robbed of the breath of life,
that we realized for the first
time that music is more than style,
technique and the expression
of powerful feelings;
music reached out beyond
political boundaries,
national hatred and
the horse of war.
On no other occasion have I seen
so clearly what direction
music must take".
So, that definitely shows us,
I think that Hindemith was a
very enlightened individual,
he was thinking about
what he was experiencing,
and this kind of discourse
on the role of music
in these conflict situations
plays an interesting role
in the rest of his life.
And this is very much the
formative period with this --
because he got into conflicts of
course, with the Nazis later on,
in terms of his positions, and
the conservatory, and advocating
for composers who were being pushed
out for political or
religious reasons.
This is the foundation of Hindemith,
as the sort of noble, intellectual,
standing up for what's
right through his music.
He wasn't a radical with
it, at all, it's more --
it fits into this concept
of expressionism,
where he was using the music to give
a very individualized accounting
of emotions and personal responses,
especially through the text based
works, the vocal chamber music,
which we're going to
get into in depth.
One other joke that he made
about the bass drum in his time
of service, was, "I was assured
that this instrument had never been
before treated so rhythmically;
service is not so hard, I have
a lot of free time and can work
in what I want", end quote.
So, later in the war, on
May of 1918, in Flanders,
where he was stationed, he writes
about his experiences of being,
really on the frontlines,
rather than several
kilometers back before, right?
If you're playing as
a string quartet,
while people are dying it's not --
you're probably not
on the frontlines.
So, he writes about being closer
to the combat situation, quote,
"Towards the evening, eight
bombs were thrown near the town,
one hit the ammunition convoy
that [inaudible] 10 minutes away
from us, a horrible sight.
Blood, bodies full of holes,
brains, a torn off horse's head,
splintered bones, dreadful; how
mean and indifferent one becomes.
I don't think I could've eaten
or worked in peace before,
since such a sight -- excuse me --
after seeing such a sight, and now,
one sits at home again;
writing, chatting in a good mood,
not thinking about how soon
the bell could toll for us.
It's gradually becoming creepy here,
we're going to withdraw unharmed".
There's a lot of different
emotions going on, right?
He's going from being at a
pretty protected situation,
to being more towards the combat
experience, seeing what's going on,
and I think a lot of the sort of --
the concepts that he is reflecting
on, on that statement in terms
of experiencing and
witnessing visually, the gore
and the death come through in a
lot of the text that he selected
for his musical compositions.
When he heard of the end of
the war, in November 1918,
he described the experience
of hearing the news as,
"An event that I should never
forget, for the rest of my life",
and after that point he went back
to Frankfurt to continue composing,
and he took back his position
in the Upper Orchestra.
This is another interesting
quote that --
a musicologist wrote about Hindemith
in 1929, biograph [inaudible]
and music and letters, and reads
the mentality of Hindemith,
as definitely of the present and not
of the past, he follows the events
and happenings of the
world about him,
and makes use of contemporary
methods of thought and expression,
but never drifts into mere
mouth pieces for his generation.
His personal equation is too strong.
This is a scan of Hindemith's
military passport from 1918
that the Hindemith
Foundation has digitized,
so it's pretty interesting.
This is that quote
regarding the Debussy --
So, to describe his
compositional output,
during and around World War One,
there were kind of three groups
that I'm referring to the pieces as.
The first group is vocal chamber
music, which might be voice
and piano, or voice and chamber
ensemble, multiple instruments.
There's also instrumental music
that didn't have a specific
program associated with it,
which he had several of; one of
these, is the Andante et Scherzo
for clarinets, horn and piano,
from 1914, that's his opus one.
That manuscript is lost, there are
three of his works from this period
that -- which are lost within this
instrumental chamber category.
He composed his first two
string quartets during the war,
first one in 1915, and
the second one in 1918
that was one was fully
composed while he was
out in service in Flanders.
He also composed this
piano quintet in 1917,
a sonata for flute clarinet,
bass clarinet, horn, bassoon
and string quintet in 1917.
Three pieces for cello and piano in
1917, sonata for violin; opus 11-6,
a couple sonatas for violin and
a handful of solo piano works.
Of the orchestral works,
this is very much the least
of his focus I think,
in this period.
The first orchestra work during
the World War One period,
was the cello concerto in E flat,
opus three, completed in 1915-1916,
a Lustige Sinfoniatta, for small
orchestra opus four, and then,
in the '1920s was really when he
delve into the common music series,
which I just sort of --
chamber orchestra or large
chamber ensemble size works.
Which kind of served, I suppose the
more text specific book of works,
and then his sort of
trying to think of things,
maybe more in the abstract
or be more objective.
There's a lot about
Hindemith that's conflicting,
in terms of what he's trying to do.
So, at the same time, he had
this really kind of dark,
grim vocal works that were setting
the text of Rocca [phonetic],
and [inaudible] who we'll get to.
He's also trying out instrumental
music that doesn't seem necessarily
to be saying as much, and there
might be reasons for that,
which we'll get into in a moment.
He also sets interestingly --
this was the one exception
to this non-cross
over business between genres.
So, Whitman poetry throughout his
life, and the revolutionary hymn
which he used, he also
used the same musical theme
from that vocal setting in
the string quartet, opus 16,
which is interesting I think.
The Rilke poetry that he go into,
different from the expressionist
folks like [inaudible]
in that it was seeking to go more
after this new objectivity movement,
rather than the expressionist
movement.
So, we have this juxtaposition
of let's look inward,
let's tell our personal experience,
or let's convey the experience
of a figure in the text, to this
quote and quote, objective music
that seems to ignore what's
actually going on in society.
And maybe, he's making a
commentary that some parts
of society ignore what's
actually going on, regardless --
maybe because their
position in society.
And then, others being much
more directly affected.
One of the great quotes from the
phrasure by [inaudible] from music
and letters, was that
Hindemith sought to bring art
down to the level of life and to
raise life to the level of art.
So, there's this constant struggle
between where the music is being
positioned, in terms of relevance
for himself, and also
for his audiences.
The specific works that
we're going to get into,
from the expressionist
period, represent response
to what encyclopedia
pretend to call the chaos
and suffering of modern life.
There's a lot of references to
colors, and the texts, which may
or may not have relevance
to text painting.
But, I think in one of the
songs that we're going to hear,
there's this reference to
the color red, over and over,
throughout the movement, says this
woman becomes completely sucked
in to the morbidity of
the situation in Germany.
And the red is representing this
figure that's almost like death,
the grim reaper coming in the form
of a little boy, which
is kind of creepy.
The new objectivity works, are
very much the transition away
from this expressionist
work that he did.
So, very much from the string
quartets from the '1920s,
and then first common music
opus 24 in 1922, and you'll see
in this sequencing of the
pieces that we're looking at,
some of the expressionist
stuff was overlapping
with this new objectivity business.
So, that's that sort of cross
currents happening simultaneously.
Some of the concepts
that Hindemith addresses
in the World War One text
settings, come up again and again,
in some of his more famous
works, from later in his career,
including Mathis der
Maler, which tells the story
of Matthias Grünewald, the
painter, and the Harmonie der Welt,
which tells the story about Kepler.
Both of those operas deal with the
conflict of the individual identity,
and the sort of situation of social
upheaval, regardless of the context.
So, I think, Hindemith
throughout his career,
even though he didn't spend all of
his time focusing on social issues
in his music, there's definitely
this thing about him that sticks
to that topic, whether it's specific
to World War One experiences,
whether is revisiting
historical figures,
and seeing how history
repeats itself unfortunately.
And the two figures
that we've chosen
for those opera settings
were described
as his two heroes in history.
So, that definitely -- I
think shows that he's thinking
about these issues
on a long-term basis.
The particular use of the vocal
music, to get across some kind
of social commentary, is
result of Hindemith's thinking
that the voice was,
quote, "The most natural
of music utterances" end quote.
So, there was a definite sense
that he can do something more
with the vocal music, that he
can with the instrumental music.
OK, do you want to listen to music?
Yes, great.
Before we do that, this is the
Opera House Orchestra in 1920,
and I believe this is Hindemith,
right here, where the cursor is,
just right there, I wonder
if you can see him, but --
It's just some of the selected
World War One era works,
if you were here early,
the first piece
that we were playing
was Melancholie opus 13,
and that piece was
dedicated specifically
to Hindemith's friend Karl Köhler,
who was in service with him
and was killed in 1918, you
also heard after Melancholie,
[inaudible], which is the setting
for soprano in eight instruments.
This uses a text by pod
-- more mid-19th century.
And the first one is in a character
Die Junge Magd, which we're going
to listen a lot to, and [inaudible]
kind of veers off into the absurdus,
which is really interesting I think.
And it gets into talking about
a tree frog, having a mustache,
wild boars, oxes wearing
hats, goose --
geese on stilts, talking
about that being peculiar sort
of demonic dances, drafts wearing
ties, and flying elephants,
there are references to crocodiles
in the Nile, etcetera, etcetera.
It's kind of -- I'll
place them for you.
It's -- if we want to connect
this work, to World War One,
my suggestion would be
to think of it as sort
of representing the craziness
of what was going on.
[ Music ]
So, he clearly had a lot
of time on its hands,
while serving in World War One.
I think that piece goes to
show that Hindemith's own sort
of personal emotional
state, was stable enough
to experience happy things,
and to convey happy emotions while
he could also convey really sort
of depressing, solemn, deathly kinds
of feelings, as we
will get into now.
So, hold on, for some of that.
The piece that I'd like
to focus on mostly today,
is called the Junge Magd,
it's opus 23 number two,
it lasts about seven minutes
long, and it is comprised --
it consists of six poems,
that ends by Georg Trakl.
Trakl was an Austrian gentleman; he
was born in 1887, and died in 1914,
he served in World War One for
a period as a medical officer,
dealing with dispensing medication
to people who were injured.
And he kind of had a
history of depression,
and he killed himself unfortunately
in 1914, because he couldn't cope
with what he was witnessing.
So, that kind of gives a tragic
spin to his poetry, unsurprising,
and these poems tell the story of
an anonymous young maid who was
at parallel with the world
filled with destruction, war,
totalitarian rule -- getting
there -- and also despair.
The poetry is definitely written
in the expressionist movement,
and with here, constructing imagery
and poetic devices that combines
with text painting and a
haunting musical soundscape,
to bring the life of sorrows, of
a generation of young Europeans,
and more broadly Germans
-- excuse me --
Germans, and more broadly Europeans.
There is this specific device that
Hindemith uses in each of the songs,
and it's sort of a
cyclical structure,
so the musical material is kind
of revolving around of itself,
and even though he'll have separate
subject figures at certain points,
one will start, the
second one will start,
then they'll overlap a little bit,
and come back to the
beginning point,
almost consistently
throughout, which is getting
to that cyclical history,
kind of commentary.
So, you all have a handout,
hopefully, which has some
of the pages from the Junge
Magd, just to give you a sense.
The basic narrative arch is that
we start out with the maiden,
kind of getting by in life,
dealing with whatever is going on,
and then she falls apart from
song to song, and by the end,
death has taken her away.
Can we kind of see the collapse
-- or hear the collapse.
[ Music ]
Should be the first
page of your handout.
[ Music ]
Translation if up here
if you'd like to see it.
[ Music ]
Right, so I gave you a taste of --
from my listening to this piece,
I hear this movement as
the woman kind of surviving
and not really recognizing
what's going on,
outside of her existence
for the sake of coping.
There's a lot -- a lot of kind of
interesting things that he does
with text painting; which we're
not going to get to all of them,
unfortunately, just because of time.
But, there are moments where he will
insert fluttering figures for --
for example, in the second verse,
you see here in the
beeches jackdaws flutter,
and he constructs visualizations
of oral depictions
of her shadow happening,
or her hair fluttering,
and rat screaming in
the art, etcetera.
But, what I think it's really
cool about this repertoire
from Hindemith, is that it is
so gorgeous, in terms of --
for me at least, the mood
of the music, the writing,
the lyrical writing is
incredible for the voices,
and from my own experience of
people interacting with Hindemith,
I think this period gets
ignored a little bit for a lot
of his later work, and there are a
lot of things about his later work,
that I think he doesn't
necessarily do in this era.
He's much more concise in here,
it is not about the viola;
no offense to the viola players.
But, anyways.
Then, this is the third verse of the
first piece, "And enticed by decay,
she lowers her inflamed eye
lids, parts grass, indicate bond,
and bends down to her feet."
In the second song, we get into
the woman being a bit lonely,
she is working in her chamber
whether that's cleaning,
or spinning or something like that.
She's alone, that's the
point of the history.
And the text from [inaudible]
reads, "Silently solemnly,
she works on the chamber, and
the yard lies long desolate.
In the elder tress by the chamber,
a blackbird flutes pitifully.
Silver-ly her image in the
mirror looks at her strangely
in the twilight-glow, and
dusks sickly in the mirror,
and she shutters before its purity".
So, I think the woman is recognizing
there's a change happening
within herself that is
starting to be apparent.
"Dream like a farm-boy sings in
the dark, and she stares shaken
with pain, redness stickles through
the dark, suddenly at the gate,
the south wind shakes", this is
the first instance in the cycle,
where you hear the reference to the
color red, and also, the farm-boy,
maybe representing innocence of
young people going to have to war,
but in fact, while they seem
so familiar and charming,
they are killing each
other, which is depressing,
and they'll probably come for her.
In the -- in that same song,
Hindemith uses a rhythmic motive,
to depict the shaking, and he does
that throughout all of the songs,
any descriptive word or additive,
or whatever he's doing --
there is a motive that can
be associated with that.
And so, shaking comes back
a lot through the songs;
he doesn't necessarily
use the same figure,
but he uses something
that's very obvious
to the listener that
can be identified.
All right.
The third piece in the cycle,
which you have the first page of,
start off with the clarinet.
Let's get that up for you.
So, in the text here, which
I'll plug in a second,
it describes the woman having
fever's dreams, and there's all kind
of stuff going on outside, that sort
of the background to her experience.
And grudgingly the
morning comes back.
[ Music ]
This is the second verse text now.
You can kind of hear this
representation of exhaustion,
where it's just like a gas
up there, it's healing.
[ Music ]
There in the world Earth,
it's sudden a darker,
more grounded, rich kind of sound.
OK, great.
On the fourth song, this
is now the woman woken
up from whatever the situation was,
or her body sort of being there,
reacting to the feverish
experience, and what is coming next.
Lengthily sprawled out
on the bed -- oh, no.
I spoiled the story, sorry.
The hammer clinging is now, right?
So, this smithy or smith claims
that he hanged up his hammer,
and she scurries past
the gate, "In red glow,
the farm-boy swings the hammer, and
death like, she looks over there,
as in the dream, she's struck
by his laughter, and she tumbles
into the smithies smile, childly
cringing before his laughter,
like the hammer hard and course.
Brightly in the room, sparks spray,
and with helpless gestures she
snatches after the wild sparks,
and falls daze to the earth."
So, there's something about
the boy, and this kind of red
and fire imagery that
is pulling her forward,
perhaps not on her own will,
which probably quite
obviously represents death.
And this is kind of the harshest
songs that ends in the cycle.
I'll give you a taste of it.
Loop.
[ Music ]
So, there's' a big
transition incoming --
this transition is kind of back
to the dream state,
a recollection of it.
[ Music ]
The rhythm is almost that
corner sort of craze laughter,
or nervous laughter I think.
[ Music ]
This is now third verse, coming back
to the opening figure of the hammer.
[ Music ]
That's another word that
ends with the word Earth,
and the descent in
pitch, which is --
I'll get that, yes.
So, the fifth song, which I'm not
going to play any off, gets into --
this is the imagery of her being
in the bed, "Lengthily sprawled
out on the bed, she wakes
filled with sweet trembling,
and she sees her soil bed,
hidden by a golden light.
Mignonettes there at the window,
and the blueish brightness of sky,
sometimes the wind carries to the
window a bell's hesitant tinkling.
Shadows glide over the
pillow, noon strides lowly,
and she breaths heavily
on the pillow,
and her mouth is like a wound".
Then in the last song, number six,
"in the evening bloody lemons float,
clouds over silent forests that
are wrapped in black linens,
sparrows buzz in the fields, and she
lies completely white in darkness,
under the foot, a cueing wasp
away, like a carrion in bush,
in darkness flies world
around her mouth."
Kind of dark stuff happening at
the same time as sort of reference
of her being white, which yes, it's
her being dead probably, or ill,
but at the same time, white is
representing pure things, right?
So, there's this juxtaposition
of the light and the darkness,
with the golden light that it's
mentioned in the previous one.
And the carrion refers to
kind of carcasses stuff,
which is unpleasant, so if
you imagine that swirling
around someone's mouth, "And
dream like in the brown hamlet,
a sound of dance and fiddle
echoes, floats are continents
through the hamlet, blows
her hair in their branches."
We'll have you just
listen to this last song.
Too perky.
Thinking the good ones represent
sort of the innocence and purity,
which I'm actually happy about.
History not so much, and
there, the strings are muted.
[ Music ]
So, kind of an interesting ending.
The use of the lower range of
the clarinet, and then the cello
at the end, I think it's going back
to this figure that he was using
in other songs, where it's
the Earth and everything going
down at the bottom, and this perhaps
it's her returning to the Earth,
or going somewhere else
after the death experience.
The little -- turned
at happy at the end,
I think it's probably
indicative of hopefulness,
and a sense that the
despair can be overcome,
which is certainly something
that Hindemith had to face,
on its own personal level,
in a very significant way,
to lead up to World War Two.
But, how do we connect all
of this to the library?
This definitely gives
you a sense of what kind
of things were happening
creatively in music
with Europeans composers
during World War One,
and in the period right after it,
it was not something
they could really ignore,
even if they were trying to.
Just in terms of the text they
were choosing to work with,
and in terms of what was
going on in their own lives.
If your father just died in
combat, you'd be in a strange --
I'm sure that's going to have some
kind of effect in your psyche.
And then, his own service, and
the evolution of its beliefs
about the war, and German
positioning, politically.
So, Hindemith came to know,
"This is college, yes."
This is the best time to Tweet
about the Library, right?
So, Miss Cullage [phonetic] and
Hindemith first became acquainted
through correspondence, and
through Hindemith submission
for a commission competition
that she used to run
at the Berkshire Festival
that she created -- this is --
contemporary to her having started
the series here in the library,
and this is referring to
the '1930s specifically.
Hindemith, made his USA debut
performing his own repertoire,
with some ensembles
here at the Library,
doing the eight Cullage Festival
in 1937, right next door,
and we have -- oh, I
stopped to put it out --
the design program from that
concert, which is really cool,
so I'll put that up in a second.
And then, the relationship
continued as you can see in some
of the correspondence over here,
and Hindemith was commissioned
by Miss Cullage on several
occasions, both by her privately,
and by the foundation that
was already at the Library.
And the significant one that the
Library commission was his Ballet
Hérodiade, which was performed
on the same performance
as [foreign language] when it
debut in 1944, so it's pretty cool.
This is the new review of some the
treasures related to Hindemith,
that are here and most of
them are on view for you.
And the Cullage Foundation
Commissions
and Scores included Canona Tray
[phonetic], which is a gift score
to Miss Cullage, the ballet
commission Hérodiade from '44.
Quasi-piano concerto worked
all concert music for piano,
[foreign language] which
was the personal commission
that Miss Cullage paid for.
And then, a gift of a set
of songs, to all texts,
which are here in the bottom left.
The other archive that has
a lot of Hindemith's stuff,
is the Moldenar Archives [phonetic]
I haven't gotten enough in depth,
to know if Hindemith was
selling stuff to the Moldenars
of if he was gifting it
to them for other reasons,
but there are some things over there
that are as mundane as envelopes,
in which Hindemith sent
goodies to the Moldenars,
which I find interesting, because
there are old stamps on there,
and German look posts down
below, as well as some telegrams,
and a little gift compositions
that he made for Miss Cullage
on her birthday; there's one in
a box, that's literally composed
on the box, and there's
another one which is
in a piece paper, which
is kind of cool.
Published edition of [foreign
language] which we heard,
and there's a series of letters
between Hindemith and Miss Cullage,
about the 1930 commission
for that piano work,
starting from the telegrams
in the left,
were he is offered the
commission and he accepts,
and going on the exchange of money,
there is the deposit check for some
of the funds there,
which is kind of cool.
And then, in the second table
there's correspondence relating
to the ballet commission,
and the library's correspondence
with him about that.
This is just a small sampling of
the correspondence that exists.
So, there's a lot of interesting
stuff to delve into there.
So, in summary, we had a little
exploration of Hindemith,
as a World War One musical figure.
We looked at some of its works
on a broad scope, and then,
we looked at a couple of them,
especially the Junge Magd in detail.
My hope for you is that
this is picked some interest
in the World War One period,
and also in the musicians
and the artists that were
interacting with the time.
And hopefully, make
you even more eager
to go see the new exhibit
that's opening in April.
Now, granted that the exhibits
that the library is doing are
slanted towards the American
participation in the war.
I think with figures like
Hindemith, who became so integral
to American musical life in the
20th century, because he lived there
and taught here, and
because he had a relationship
with the Library, I think.
If he used this to think about
the World War I involvement
of the United States
as more than just
when the troops went over there.
And that is that.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov